i can imagine being
your lawyer in the 80s had to be a
stressful and also profitable gig to
take yeah he made a lot of money yeah
i bet he did
i bet he did he kept us out of jail
though i bet he did that was that was
the most important thing is keep my guys
out of jail that had to be nice to have
somebody like that in your corner to
kind of guide you through the legalities
of like hey oh yeah you're gonna put if
you're gonna take your money and put it
here do it this way really one of the
best things he ever told me was uh i go
to him and i was like man these cops
playing dope
planting dope yeah they was playing dope
on this yeah because they couldn't catch
us they couldn't figure out
how to catch us with dope you know we
we i came up with a theory was that we
don't keep dope in the house
we brain in the house we wear it up as
soon as we wear that we throw it in the
trunk of a car put the car down the
street in front of somebody else's house
so they was never going to catch us with
dope unless they called us like right
during that time right now that specific
instance and then we started weighing it
up at three in the morning four in the
morning you know like odd hours of the
day when when most people would be
asleep so people wouldn't see us
going in houses or something like that
because you know people would see me
sometimes recognize me and be like oh
that's a red cross
so we just started doing it when most
people would be asleep so nobody
wouldn't really recognize it so
the cops couldn't catch us with dope
and back then it wasn't no
conspiracy you know like um
well conspiracy somebody got to get
caught with some dope with a conspiracy
or somebody got to come in and say that
you had some dope but anyway uh they
started planting the drugs on us they
started raiding the house
and would literally
take dope out of their pocket and plant
it in the house or take bags of dope out
of the trunk of their car
and so how did your lawyer tell you to
navigate through that well when i told
him about it he didn't believe it you
know california yeah no no that's a
crazy thing yeah ain't nobody doing no
[ __ ] like that in california so he said
if if if i knew some cops was was was
crooked like that there i would hire a
private investigator to investigate the
cops that's what i did
so you would hire a private investigator
now
this would be pre
them planning drugs or after they'd
already been planting drugs they're
planting drugs on my people already they
hadn't planted drugs on me and you knew
who these cops were
yeah so you would say it was the freeway
task force they was named after me so
you would hire a private investigator to
investigate those cops yeah and just get
get [ __ ] on them yeah
that's great what was the craziest thing
that your pi dug up on a cop
uh this one guy was was was um in the
bed with his girl
and
he had a fish tank right next to his bed
where one of the pumps had a shortage in
it
so it was electrocuting
they stuck the guy onto the wire
and and electrocuted him
so the cops
did that to someone
yeah and your pi
witnessed this he didn't witness it but
the the the defendants
or the witnesses told him that that's
what happened to him another one was my
partner
we used to have big safes probably like
the size of this table in our apartments
and
they wanted him to open the safe
and he wouldn't open it so they took a
trash bag and put over his head [ __ ]
some torture and [ __ ] try to suffocate
they got indicted for that
for putting the trash bag over over his
head
smothering me wow
so it was almost like
against their best interest to [ __ ] with
you in that way because you had a
[ __ ] guy who was gonna i guess
overturn all that [ __ ] well eventually
we we got it all over tournament uh when
i turned my investigation in 150 people
got out of prison
when you when you ended up going in or
when you ended up turning in and died of
me i got they eventually indicted me
okay so when they indicted me
you had all this [ __ ] that your p.i had
accumulated like oh you're going to go
to trial with these guys this is
what we got on them this your witnesses
right let me show you terrible witness
let me show you who your witnesses is
wow that's crazy that's how that's how i
beat my first case shout out to your pi
huh is he i mean that's your lawyer and
your pi in the 80s god bless them they
had
in top of the line guys
he probably did now too his name was
frenchie frenchy he was the ex-cop
i mean so he knew yeah he knew he knew
the ropes he knew the ropes but those
are the guys that you get for
investigators you know if you do an
investigation on cops you know you want
somebody who's who's been there done
that
that's some real [ __ ]